[Music]
okay
it's me Deb and it's almost Valentine's
Day so I'm gonna show you how to seduce
your tinder Ella or your prince tinder
charming with a meal that's gonna keep
you going oh not long Debbie seriously
all night just from dinner oh yeah
did you know that eating a meal filled
with avocados and oysters and chocolate
can boost your libido through the roof
huh that's mildly unattractive whatever
Abbi this meal is gonna give me one of
the best Oregon soaps of my life now I
just need to find a Valentine's Day date
right okay Debbie well I'm gonna tell
you why that might not be the case let's
take a look at what everyone's saying
about aphrodisiac foods which is that
they are awesome
I needed uh red wine avocados Chili's
chocolate okay there Debbie let's get
real here I love all these foods I'm not
gonna lie but there's not a whole lot of
evidence out there that any of these
foods have any kind of impact on our sex
drives a lot of those foods get their
aphrodisiac title because of some of the
nutrients they contain others are
grounded in mythology or symbolism and
others still are just kind of plain
random but whatever the case the
research doesn't lie whatever guys I
know you need this Valentine's Day and
it starts with a big plate of these big
juicy sexy teen lipsticks well I'm glad
you like oysters Debbie because there
are a great source of lean protein but
they're not edible viagra I think the
oysters probably got their aphrodisiac
title because they are loaded with zinc
which is a really important nutrient for
male sex hormones but unfortunately the
research suggests it's not linked to sex
drive for men in any kind of way
alternatively if you're into slippery
wet foods that look a bit like testicles
then kudos to you Debs I say slipping
back they might just do the trick all
right then what about chili peppers my
day is gonna be hot as hell that's cool
Debbie I look a good kick too but
Chili's are not magic either it's super
far-fetched I think probably the
connection comes from a lot of people
thinking that when they eat hot food
they get sweaty and their heart races
and that might remind them of sex I
don't know but if that's what you're
going for I have one piece of advice for
you
whatever you do don't eat chilies and
then go downtown what think about that
one for a minute
ouch okay then I'd be let's just eat
chocolate chocolate is safe for my lady
parts and is such an aphrodisiac so
chocolate has been thought to help raise
our feel-good hormone serotonin which
might put us in a good mood but one
study actually looked at whether or not
chocolate have any impact on sexual
desire and sadly no days what know what
Abbi I don't get it I still feel like
these foods put me in the mood what is
the science not getting at well Debbie
it might be the placebo effect in
scientific trials participants are often
either given treatment or a placebo like
a sugar pill for example and in this
case the participants and often the
researchers themselves don't actually
know who's being given the treatment and
who hasn't so that way they can avoid
people changing their behaviors or their
experiences thinking that they've been
given a treatment it's very possible
that food puts us in the mood because we
think it will or expect that it well
it's also possible that a food just puts
us in a good mood and that's usually the
first step to getting intimate well in
that case just bring out a juice cleanse
there's nothing like a green juice to
make me smile whatever works Debbie
whatever works for you the bottom line
is that this Valentine's Day and really
any day of the year
focus on enjoying foods that actually
make you feel good so that might be a
poutine and chocolate or it's some
asparagus and some fresh beautiful eggs
whatever it is you know that should be
your priority this valentine's day and
if you want some top tips on avoiding HP
valentine's day head on over to this
video right here so of course if you
like this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
what you're serving this valentine's day
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on Abbey's kitchen
you